after upstate Mike Pompeo is demanding
an investigation into the origins of the
current uh virus we discussed this in an
interview on Friday as the president
this weekend questioned China's role in
the pandemic for the very first time
wondering if it was actually an accident
watch this the question was asked would
you be angry at China well the answer
might very well be a very resounding yes
but it depends was it a mistake that got
out of control
or was it done deliberately okay that's
a big difference between those two in
either event they should have let us go
in you know we asked to go in very early
and they didn't want us in I think they
were embarrassed former White House
chief strategist Steve Bannon was among
the first to raise a red flag on China's
deception he wrote an op-ed last May
that the US was already at war with the
communist country and he joins him right
now to talk more about it Steve it's
great to see you thanks for being here
thanks for having me on Maria Steve that
was the first time the president
actually publicly raised the question of
was it deliberate I found that stunning
you haven't heard the president raised
such an issue before your reaction well
the key phrases the president used and I
think if I was in Beijing I'd be very
nervous right now he said knowingly
responsible knowingly responsible and I
think let's set aside for a second this
is a biological Chernobyl but let's set
aside a second the lab and did it leak
out of the lab with a technician on
trying to find a vaccine let's leave
aside the fact that were they doing
gain-of-function experiments there
against everybody's knowledge let's
leave aside for a second whether they
have a offensive biological weapons
program that's all going to be
investigated as Pompeo and Senator
cotton says that's all now being
investigated by intelligence services by
the world's Health Organization's etc
let's go back to knowingly responsible
and let's be precise this is not the
Chinese people and this is not China the
Chinese people the decent hard-working
people of China are the single biggest
victims here this is about the Chinese
Communist Party and they are knowingly
responsible for what happened there's an
act of commission they knew as a matter
of
Act no later than the last week of
December of 2019 they knew they had
human human transmission and community
spread the free were free Chinese in the
Republic of Taiwan and replica China
Taiwan notified the World Health
Organization on January 31st one of my
broadcasting partners miles guo
broadcasted on the 31st about human and
human transmission most importantly the
great martyr of this process in china
dr. lee and his colleagues in Wuhan the
doctors were on WeChat telling everybody
get ready we have human and human
transmission that coming into the
hospitals now the Chinese carnage party
timeline we we have a timeline because
it was December 10th one of the earliest
known coronavirus patients falling ill
in Wuhan China and you're right the
doctor raises the alarm on the corner
virus on December 30th what happens then
Steve he gets arrested he's dead now as
you know from coronavirus well he's
arrested he's also tortured his family
is is is it's put under surveillance and
they force him to sign a document that
says he's a rumor monger that these are
lies that there's not human to human
transmission the Chinese Communist Party
at the highest level that is President
Xi and Wan Shi Shan knowingly understood
they had human human transmission we
also know now from Scott Gottlieb and
also from a report by Chinese doctor at
Southampton University in the United
Kingdom that if they had acted like any
human being would act decent human if
they had acted as late as the last week
in December 95% of all this would not
have happened that is the crime here
that's the tragedy here all the 40,000
Americans that will be dead by tomorrow
morning all the victims in Wuhan that
could be tens or hundreds of thousands
all the dead in Lombardy all the doctors
and nurses all the blood of all that is
on the Chinese Communist Party's hands
on sheet and Wan Chi Shan and their
other gangsters also all the economic
carnage it's going to take us decades to
work our way out of here
eventually all of that is squarely on
the Chinese Communist Party not that
Chinese people remember there were
hundreds of thousands of innocent
Chinese
all over the world in the month of
January they didn't know that they had
the virus the Chinese Communist Party
hid this they hid it at the White House
on the meetings on the 14th and when
they signed the World Health
Organization put out a document on the
12th and then they tweeted on the 14th
after consultation with senior Chinese
medical officials there's no human to
human transmission while they're at the
White House then they go to dabba sure
when the first ones to actually report
this they don't tell anybody and when
they and actually when they started to
stop the transfer the traffic in the and
the travel inside of China they didn't
stop it to the rest of the world it took
Donald J Trump the 45th president United
States against his medical advisors
opinion because they were going off what
the World Health Organization said it
was Trump right stopped the
international travel on the 31st of
January the blood is on the hands of the
Chinese Communist Party in the world for
the Chinese people the people of Wuhan
and obey the world must hold these
people accountable will the world hold
them accountable I mean the line is
continuing as we speak yesterday at the
president's task force press conference
they showed a graphic of the mortality
rate Steve I mean it's laughable to
think that China is all the way at the
bottom of this chart when you've got so
many cases across the world and deaths
look at where China is I mean are we
supposed to believe that there are fewer
deaths in China than anywhere in the
world I think it was very powerful that
President Trump actually interrupted dr.
Burks his presentation which he never
does when she's talking about numbers to
actually point out it's so egregious we
had on our show yesterday from China
people are saying the urns themselves
they cremated their urns and there's 40
or 50,000 urns that people in Wuhan
think that they're probably over a
hundred thousand people in Wuhan that
died and forget the rest of China we
don't know because they lie about
everything but use ask about how they're
going to be held accountable the the
righteous indignation of the peoples of
the world are going to stand up and make
sure that they're held accountable
president Trump laid it out knowingly
responsible they are knowingly
responsible for the acts of commission
that all of this could have been avoided
remember 60 days ago we had the greatest
economy in American history the whole
world was prosperous we were looking for
a great 2020 a great kickoff to a decade
now we're looking at economic carnage
and the largest mass casualty event in
American history caused by a biological
Chernobyl and the lies
misrepresentations in the cover of
cotton who couldn't be on here today
calls it the biggest cover-up in world
history it's incumbent upon the
intelligence services it's a comment
upon the nations of the earth but I got
to come together
well the question that I'm asking is
isn't it wild that no one got infected
in Beijing wow what a novel thought I
mean Wuhan five million people start
traveling some people went to Italy some
people went to the United States by the
way four hundred and thirty three
thousand people traveled from China to
the United States after it was known
that the kernel virus was was was
happening but nobody got infected in
Beijing I've got to move on to the
election how is this gonna impact the
election do you think Joe Biden is going
to be the Democrat candidate given his
experience with China
well first off he's by far the weakest
candidate he's totally compromised
remember President Obama basically had a
Biden as his wingman to do everything
with China his compromise by the Chinese
Communist Party he is personally
compromised by the Chinese Communist
Party and that'll all be laid out in
details as families in business with
them but he has made every bad decision
in this manage decline of the United
States it was Joe Biden but Joe Biden
was saying last summer hey China is not
no problem China is not a problem it was
Joe Biden that took the side of the
Chinese Communist Party he was a useful
idiot for the Chinese when President
Trump stands up and says hey we got to
stop the traffic coming in here and we
have to quarantine the people that come
in it was Biden that took the Beijing
party line it was Biden that went right
- oh it's Senna phobic it's native it's
racist so is he the candidate is he the
candidate or the Democrat I think it's a
Democrat if the difference were making
too many gaps the Democratic Party has
no chance of beating Donald J Trump with
Joe Biden it's not going to happen Joe
Biden is totally compromised by the
Chinese Communist Party and by his
actions and by his actions by the way
I'm naming say about his health and how
fuzzy you know how unfocused he looks
when he comes on his his proof of life
podcast that he puts out every three
weeks
Ronna
Daniel at the RNC says something I
thought was your candidate or not Steve
are they gonna replace him as a
candidate you think I think I think at
the convention they're gonna look very
seriously replacing Biden and have
somebody that can really take on Trump
Biden cannot take on Donald Trump no way
not on China and not on any other topic
Steve Steve it's great to see this one I
thank you Steve